with the corona virus pandemic rattling
economies around Europe the question of
how the block will respond hangs in the
air so-called corona bonds a form of
shared debt among EU nations has been
mooted as a solution but that's exposed
a rift between countries like Italy and
Spain calling for the bonds and others
like Germany and the Netherlands who are
against them it is one of the elements
testing European solidarity in a time of
crisis hospitals in Italy have faced a
massive challenge to treat all their
patients critically ill with Kovan 19
disease Spain's Prime Minister has
called the pandemic Europe's biggest
crisis since the second world war but
help has come for some in the form of
the German air force specially equipped
Luftwaffe planes have flown Kovac
patients from Italy and France to
hospitals in Germany in all more than
200 sick people have been transferred
from European countries even in the time
of corona Germany sees itself as a good
European and we will show solidarity
we've proved that in the past but this
is a crisis that affects us all both in
terms of health and economically and
financially that's why we must take care
in these times that the EU stays
together but when it comes to financial
help Germany is less ready to offer
everything that is asked for the EU has
agreed big support packages worth more
than three trillion euros to counter the
economic effects of the crisis such as
the huge hit to European tourism but
Italy France and Spain would like
Brussels to go further and issue Korona
bonds a new form of shared debt many
German politicians worry that would put
new burdens on the German taxpayer this
crisis is no reason to bring in through
the backdoor financial instruments that
involve public debt which were wrong in
the past and will be wrong in the future
Korona bonds would lead to more debt
and also mean that all of Europe
ultimately lose it but others say if
European unity means anything it should
be about flexing Germany's economic
muscles during this crisis temporary
coupons we need temporary Corona bonds
to help the worst-affected countries we
need them for selfish reasons too the
German car industry is reliant on
production happening in northern Italy
so it's not just about solidarity it's
in our own interest to do the smart
thing the pandemic has brought neighbors
together but it's also put strains on
relationships for individuals and
nations for now while Europe works out
how to organize aid for the long term
direct help for the sick will continue
but what about the financial sickness
that's gripping Europe DW political
correspondent Nina has joins me for more
nina good morning helped us understand
why Corona bonds are such a sensitive
topic well you have to understand that
it's not the first crisis in which
common bonds so a common financial
instrument to get money on the markets
is being discussed and by the members of
the eurozone this was also the case ten
years ago in the financial crisis and
already then it was a contentious issue
it is a financial instrument that
basically combines securities from
different European countries and you
have to remember they do share a
currency but they don't have a joint
fiscal policy so the fear by the
fiscally conservative countries like
Germany and the Netherlands is that
their own taxpayers would basically pay
for other countries liabilities now
Italy appears to have softened its
position on these Corona bonds how is
that going to be interpreted Italy's
president Conte was very adamant up
until yesterday he said that he would
have to make sure that he did
fight the battle until the very end for
Corona bonds and that there could be no
compromise and now he softened his
position ahead of an upcoming EU summit
on Thursday where EU leaders will
discuss the question of how to get out
of this crisis together and how to help
the countries that have been most
affected you have to remember that the
EU Commission is estimating that a tenth
of the bloc's economic economic
situation can actually disappear in in
this crisis so it can suffer really
badly really bad economic implications
and so it's at least Conte has now said
the president that he wants to find a
solution quickly and that there's no
time to fight for something where you'd
have to change the treaties and so he's
ready to support proposals by countries
like France and Spain that have put
proposals on the table so what should we
be expecting from EU leaders when they
meet on Thursday EU leaders will talk in
a video conference and the 27 leaders of
the European Union's countries they will
sign off a 540 billion package that is
supposed to be an emergency rescue fund
in this crisis but of course the big
question is how do you finance what
they've called a an economic recovery
fund that is more destined for long-term
economic relief and of course the topic
of corona bonds is still on the table
and it won't go away anytime soon so I
would be surprised if this was a short
summit you know Houser thank you very
much for that and here's a look at some
other stories making headlines around
the world u.s. President Donald Trump
says his new immigration ban will last
for 60 days and affect those seeking
green cards for permanent residents
earlier he had said he would sign an
executive order to suspend all
immigration in response to the corona
virus outbreak and to protect jobs the
UK Parliament has gone back to work
after some three weeks under lockdown
restrictions where a few lawmakers were
physically present in the chamber
on Tuesday and they sat far apart
instead many others joined for the first
time ever by a videoconference written
is also among the country's hardest hit
by the corona virus pandemic with the
death toll surging above 17,000 the
government has faced criticism for being
too slow to prepare for the outbreak and
imposing a lockdown but one part of its
strategy is beginning to bear fruit with
the first human trials of an anti corona
virus vaccine due to start in the UK
today a country scrambling to deal with
a corona virus pandemic this convention
center in northern England has been
turned into a makeshift hospital the
transformation took less than three
weeks the UK is racing to increase
hospital capacity to cope with an
ever-increasing caseload the British
government has been heavily criticised
for failing to prepare for the outbreak
it's now hoping to beat the virus by
investing heavily in vaccines being
developed at universities in Oxford and
London trials on humans are set to begin
on Thursday in the long run the best way
to defeat corona virus is through a
vaccine after all this is a new disease
this is uncertain science but I'm
certain that we will throw everything
we've got at developing a vaccine the
potential vaccine is based on research
into previous viruses when this new
virus emerged there was already working
on here in Oxford on the MERS
coronavirus and a vaccine was being
trialed and in humans and so what
happened was that the genetic code from
the new corona virus was discovered in
January of this year and it was possible
to go back to that genetic code and make
these new vaccines very rapidly but even
if the human trials proved successful
they offer no quick fix similar tests
are already being conducted in the
United States researchers there say it's
likely to take more than a year before a
vaccine is widely available
now to some other coronavirus news from
around the world
researchers in switzerland say it's
possible that mass vaccination could
begin there as early as October
if trials prove successful and approval
procedures are fast-tracked Singapore
has reported more than a thousand new
infections in a single day bringing its
total to more than 10,000 cases the
United Nations is warning that the
corona virus pandemic could trigger
famine in vulnerable countries the UN
says the number of people facing acute
hunger could double to more than 250
million this year alone and the US state
of Missouri has filed a lawsuit against
China saying Beijing tried to cover up
the danger posed by the virus
epidemiologists are placing great hope
in so called and tracking apps for
smartphones to help get the corona virus
pandemic under control Singapore and
South Korea already have tracking apps
but data protection regulations there
are not as strict as they are in Europe
a German company is now working with 130
specialists from Europe on a europe-wide
app in compliance with European data
protection standards the program's
anonymously record the users location
data by a bluetooth to detect and
interrupt change of infection if any
user is karana positive all users
receive an alert for more I'm joined by
Chris Bosio initiator of this European
initiative called pan European privacy
preserving proximity tracing or PEP PPT
mr. booths welcome it's quite a mouthful
there but the this initiative that
you're the co-founder of is advocating
and EU wide app and you're also advising
the German government on it how will
this app work I'm totally amazed that
you could speak the name this is what
happens when scientists scream let me
first say something very important we're
not creating an app because an app
itself has to fit in with the local
health system of a country because every
Health System is a little bit different
every the legislation around is a little
bit different the services are organized
differently so the apps will have to
integrate with that too off
the best type of integration with all
the measures and restrictions that a
country takes what we're offering at the
pet Petey is is a layer under the ABS
that does three things basically it
gives good measurement so that you know
that how far are you away from somebody
that is axe exact no point in measuring
like two meters distance when your
accuracy is only 10 meters the second is
privacy preservation arm with different
models right the idea is that that there
are different privacy models but there
is a common denominator which for Europe
at least is gdpr meaning that the simply
the only thing that could reveal a
person's identity is the person itself
and the third one is interoperability
because it's important if we loosen
restrictions in one country we still
have closed borders so the infection the
ability to trace infections has to go
beyond other countries and for this no
data is used that that actually would
allow anyone to track back a person
location data is not used Wi-Fi data is
not used your SIM card IDs or Mac IDs
and all these things are not used it's
always stays on the private level right
I love talking about technical
modalities it I really do get them but
then similar apps are being used in Asia
so what you are saying how is that
different to what's happening in Asia
well in in Asia where societies need or
want less data protection what the the
basically what was implemented was
external surveillance so face
recognition that was used or publishing
the location of sick people so other
people around that could be warned and I
don't think that is this type of
surveillance would be acceptable in in
any European democracy so our question
was I mean was obvious that this way
this could be a key building block in
quelling an outbreak and the example is
Wuhan in China or China in general but
then now in order to leave your house
you have to quit your app town and and
the house will open the door will only
open if the app says you're not in
danger of spreading an infection
so that I think is completely out of the
order for Europe so our question was can
we do something that would allow people
to still have privacy preservation I
mean the whole point is until there is a
vaccine we will have to manage this
pandemic and managing it while we still
have a life and not I'll stay at home
managing it means that we have to go and
find an infection and get the the people
that possibly could have been infected
very quickly so the infection can spread
and that's the whole idea of having an
act instead of doing interviews who did
you meet last week with someone who's
been tested positive apps the way
appears to be the way Chris boos thank
you very much for joining us thank you
the German Danish ship Essen expressed
started its journey from Europe to Asia
back in January before the corona virus
had spread around the world the crew
started becoming aware of the
seriousness of the outbreak as they
traveled closer to its epicenter now
several months on they still don't know
when they will be able to set foot on
land 366 meters long with the load
capacity of 13,000 containers the Essen
Express runs between Europe and Asia
irregularly captain Tobias come on and
his crew took off in January from the
Italian city of Genoa back then the
corona virus was not yet a pandemic few
people had even heard of it I was the
last of the crew members on land that
was also the day I had my last haircut
what the crew experienced in the
following weeks and months was like a
chronicle of the pandemic I started
while we were in Egypt some port
fighters and officials were already
wearing face masks and gloves the
further we traveled to it Asia
the more we noticed how serious the
situation really was they passed through
Swiss Canal in early February their days
on board the ship changed little it
wasn't possible to impose social
distancing restrictions the company
asked them to take body temperatures
daily and sent the crew protective gear
the captain stashed away some extra food
we found weird enough reserves for two
weeks more than usual which is the case
got stuck at some cord or authorities
ban us from leaving because someone got
infected to minimize the risk of
infection contacts with staff at the
ports were reduced to the essential and
just as the pandemic reached his peak
the Essen Express arrived in China our
pod pilots were working with full
protective gear the crew was not allowed
to go ashore and a change of crew wasn't
possible possible because many ports
won't allow it
there aren't any flights available to
send back person now or to get them on
board the pandemic spread quickly across
Europe and the essent Express crew was
trapped on board captain Kalman ordered
extra SIM cards so the crew members
could stay in touch with their families
their next stops were in Barcelona
Tangiers and Genoa where the crew had to
stay on board only the cargo of medicine
and medical equipment was unloaded just
make you feel a little proud because you
are actually helping people not just by
bringing groceries but maybe even some
face masks now they're on the way back
to Asia
perhaps the crew will finally be able to
disembark in Singapore or Hong Kong the
International Olympic Committee has been
forced to backtrack over who will bear
the costs of the postponed Tokyo games
that's after Japan complained a section
on the IOC website had wrongly coated
its prime minister saying his country
would pay the extra costs it comes as
some Japanese scientists have cast doubt
on the Olympics taking place at all next
year due to the pandemic with the
Olympic fireworks on hold until next
year games organisers faced a monumental
challenge not to mention a massive bill
but the question of who picks up that
tab is causing tension between Japan and
the International Olympic Committee a
section on the IOC website previously
said Japan
we'll continue to cover the costs as it
would have done under the terms of the
existing agreement for 2020 though in
line with contractual obligations the
sentiment angered Japan's government and
that section has since been deleted
there's no such agreement related to
additional costs stemming from the
postponement estimates suggest this
moment will cost in the range of two to
six billion dollars tough to swallow for
Japanese taxpayers especially at a time
of economic struggle the IOC aware of
the cost burden has already hinted that
next year's games may need to be scaled
back but that's if they take place at
all the Olympics attract hundreds of
thousands of people from all over the
world
when Japanese virologists thinks that
remains a recipe for disaster
in this regard I'm very pessimistic
about holding Olympic Games in next
summer unless you hold Olympic Games in
a totally different structures such as
no audience or very limited
participation or such and such
organizers say they don't have a plan B
maybe because plan a is proving
difficult enough to navigate